hey guys how's it going today we're
going to be doing the egg Roulette
challenge this was suggested by one of
you guys on Twitter what we have before
us is a dozen of eggs I boiled all
before of them and then I put them all
into the bucket of water pot of water
and then I put them back in so I
absolutely have no idea what is what and
I was so nervous doing this cuz oh like
I think I like more than that really
so I don't know what is what do you want
to go first do I do it on you know I do
it on you know I do it to you know I
pick one night hit on my head you pick
one you hit on your head I think that's
all works
I took one I hit it on your head that's
more fun shoosh Pacific wouldn't see you
touched it you take it oh I don't know I
vote in my head I'm fine
how are you supposed to do it okay so
that was a test
should I get a hammer and then we just
like hit look okay we gotta scramble
these eggs I bet you scramble it doesn't
matter I don't know I literally don't
remember work but what okay how about
this I'm gonna go get a hammer
okay get the hammer what did you miss
how do I get sucked into this doesn't
even make sense
okay so I pick one whoo yep
all right give me this Hamlet
[Music]
oh it is the most disgusting thing I've
ever seen in my life I hate it oh I'm
gonna vomit oh it's cold
okay you're next he's just dude no I
don't like it I hate this game
this was such a stupid idea can I get
you a hammer
aah aah oh no I'm not good oh my god we
hope I gotten two of them already
aah spider you're actually hitting me in
the head with a hammer
you're cheating you when do you want to
pick one who am i pick the one you want
now you're just pushing the rest of the
egg in my head oh stop it stop it
egghead Oh
you are you know one egg on head there's
still one left
I got some heron that one oh man I hate
this game do you want to pick it you're
in a bigot
just don't cheat it's not well I got
some hair in that one too one left
whose turn it is your turn it's my turn
Oh God my turn no it's my turn - okay
close your eyes no you're gonna switch
close your eyes close your eyes now
close your eyes oh oh you actually
helped I hit her really hard with the
hammer like actually I'm so sorry
oh my god I'm so sorry I felt your
cranium I wasn't expecting it to go
through that enter I'm not like I felt
like the thud yes if there's no I mean
oh I'm so sorry it just went so smoothly
through that egg oh oh you might be
bleeding oh my god I think I'm can come
don't try this at home this is dumb
honestly like I wasn't even thinking we
gotta go to the hospital I feel actually
very dizzy my bleeding no but your part
is very straight thank you I pride
myself okay um
okay we can go holy crap dude not her I
didn't mean to do that huh I didn't mean
to do it bill this is gross
oh wow I might need to go to the ER
really no but I think I should probably
be washed in my sleep tonight watch me
sleep that's up I gotta go Charlotte
okay yeah get everything out of this box
is what's really gonna happen
ps4 system a PlayStation camera bolts in
separately are required I don't actually
have a PlayStation camera so I'm gonna
have to get that
[Music]